this is a really important detail that  is not being included in the skies  falling articles about mew  excuse me  it peaked in july and has been declining  delta continues to grow  as a percentage of all cases so when you  look at the articles more transmissible  of course is concerning  then the question is what about more  deadly and often it takes a really long  time to get information about that  you've got to track hospitalization  you've got to track death rate etc  but it appears as though we have already  passed the mu peak now why they say  worrisome is  if something even worse is ultimately  going to be what knocks out delta and  becomes dominant but i actually think  that on this issue a lot of corporate  media have been spreading a lot of what  we call fud fear uncertainty and doubt  we appear to be beyond the peak of mu  delta remains dominant